consider the following coordinate pairs  and they give us a bunch right over here  which of the those pairs is not graphed  below so let's see 3 comma negative 2 so  3 comma negative 2 well actually that  looks like that first one is not graphed  so 3 comma negative 2 is in grafton you  can verify that all of these others do  seem to be graphed 4 comma negative 8 is  right there negative 8 comma 3 is right  over here 4 comma 6 4 comma 6 is right  there and negative 1 comma 0 is right  there so let's do a couple more of these  so is negative 5 comma 0 graphed yep  it's right over there negative 4 comma  positive 5 should be there so that's not  graphed so just select that one let's do  one more of these negative 8 comma 4 so  negative 8 comma 4 we got lucky the  first one is not graphed negative 8  comma 4 and we're done